straniero
[Musica]
[Musica] va
bene ciao e benvenuti a tutti
questo è actinf live streaming numero 47.0
è il 3 agosto 2022
benvenuto nell'istituto di inferenza attiva
siamo un laboratorio e istituto partecipativo online
che sta comunicando l'apprendimento
e la pratica dell'inferenza attiva applicata
che puoi  trovaci ad alcuni dei link
nella diapositiva
si tratta di un live registrato, archiviato,
trascritto e pubblicato,
quindi per favore forniscici un feedback in
modo che possiamo migliorare il nostro lavoro
tutti i background e le prospettive sono i
benvenuti e seguiremo l'
etichetta del video per il live  stream
tutte le attività dell'istituto di inferenza attiva
sono partecipative quindi
fateci sapere se volete contribuire o essere
coinvolti andate su
activeinference.org e cliccate sui link
per partecipare direttamente e per saperne di
più
stiamo per partire per un
numero dispari
e avventura unica in
47. discuteremo e
giustapponeremo non una carta come al solito,
ma avremo un approccio con più occhi aperti
verso due documenti in questa situazione
impareremo e
discuteremo
in modo giustapposto due documenti
inferenza attiva e abduzione nel 2021
di ati vaiko
pieteren e majid beni
discuteremo anche di una
cognizione sociale dinamica attiva e di
un'inferenza attiva di ines  hippolyto e thomas
van s anche dal 2021
tutti i video
puntano zero e altrimenti sono
introduzioni a queste idee e
contesto aggiuntivo non una recensione o una
valutazione o un'ultima parola
e
speriamo di utilizzare costantemente questa colorazione
di un rosso chiaro per la carta abduttiva
e  un azzurro per gli inattivi
lasciando lo spazio aperto a nuovi colori
e combinazioni che
dimostrino alcune aree di sintesi
e parleremo in questo punto zero
con alcune grandi domande e esamineremo i nostri
obiettivi oltre a leggere tra questi
obiettivi  che è un po' diverso
da molti live streaming
, quindi forniremo
informazioni generali su ciascun documento in
termini di obiettivi, affermazioni, roa  dmap e
l'abstract
passeremo quindi a una sezione sullo sfondo nel
contesto
che includerà molte informazioni
sulla semiotica dell'inazione logica abduttiva
e così via
ci sposteremo quindi in una giustapposizione
dei due articoli
e avremo un  molto tempo per
discutere, si spera, con più autori
nelle
discussioni imminenti.1.2 e forse anche oltre, quindi
oggi volevamo portare un quadro generale, il
contesto,
parlare di alcuni thread molto interessanti,
fornire un po' di background che
aiuta a entrare in questo spazio e quindi
fornire  una prima giustapposizione e
scorrere questi documenti che ancora una volta
entusiasmeranno qualcuno all'idea di leggere i
documenti, approfondire e
portare il proprio punto di vista su questi
argomenti molto interessanti,
quindi
passeremo alle
introduzioni sono daniel sono  un ricercatore in
California
e parlerò di più di ciò che è eccitante
nelle prossime diapositive lo passerò al
preside
uh buongiorno mi chiamo preside sono a
Calgary e immagino di esserlo
forse  la mente deformata che ha cercato di
mettere insieme questa idea e forse
cambiare un po' il modo in cui
guardiamo all'inferenza attiva cercando di tirare
due documenti
diversi di focus folk apparentemente diversi
e poi
entrambi
incorporando anche l'uso di
inferenze attive  come metodologia
per analizzare la situazione e quindi quali sono
le implicazioni per questo
quindi lo trovo davvero eccitante
e lo passerò a stephen
quindi grazie decano sì stephen qui sono
a toronto canada um
e sono  sono davvero
interessato a entrambi questi documenti
perché entrambi parlano molto del tipo di
approccio partecipativo in generale e dell'idea di
come le persone si stanno impegnando nel mondo,
quindi le domande
sull'inazione
sono davvero rilevanti così come lo è il
pezzo sul rapimento, quindi
ehm
mentre sono entrambi documenti abbastanza diversi
, entrambi
mi parlano abbastanza forte, quindi è davvero
interessante, quindi non vedo l'ora
di poter
esplorare in qualche modo che io'  Sto lavorando con il
teatro partecipativo
, la psicologia della comunità, lo
sviluppo della comunità
e i processi di sviluppo multi-scala e sono davvero
entusiasta
di vedere come
questa interpretazione scientifica
può soddisfare una domanda più
che potrebbe essere definita partecipativa basata sulla pratica
che io  'ho
guardato, quindi lo passerò di nuovo a
daniel
eccellente grazie a entrambi e Dean grazie
ancora per il viaggio di molti mesi
le molte e-mail, mesi
e viaggi di messaggi che abbiamo percorso
perché spero che questo si
svolga e includa  un modo che sta
portando i live streaming
e il tipo di materiale su cui stiamo
lavorando oltre dove siamo
andati
e
nello
spirito di ciò passerò il preside per
introdurre bene alcune delle grandi domande qui
se ne tirerai due  documenti che
sembrano non
avere molto in comune in termini
di argomento,
dovrai affrontarlo da un'angolazione leggermente
diversa in termini non solo di
scovare cosa c'è all'interno di un documento, ma
come potrebbero essere confrontati questi documenti,
quindi abbiamo raccolto alcune
domande sull'idea
di quale ruolo come strumento di analisi situazionale
o
inferenza attiva potrebbe svolgere un metodo di realtà
nel
tirare le cose che sembrano essere molto
lontane e separate e ingarbugliarle
e così via  le domande erano fondamentalmente l'
inferenza attiva può essere sia
qualcosa che contiene o contiene o
delimita qualcosa e anche la cosa
delimitata o afferrata cos'è l'
inferenza attiva o se cosa succede se l'enfasi attiva
sia la cosa
è contenuta
um dire una riga di partizione in una tabella
e  una cella in
modo che l'effettivo divario in cui possiamo
effettivamente inserire più informazioni in
ciò che appare come sembrerebbe
sia come vincolo che come separatore
contemporaneamente e penso che sia quel
pezzo di reciprocità che cercheremo
di tirare fuori in  i prossimi live
streaming e cosa c'è di simile o diverso
nell'avere una presa
sui modelli e un processo diverso che
è la modellazione
grazie steven vuoi  Per aggiungere
qualcosa qui
no, penso che
ne copra molto l'unica cosa
che quella x che c'è è una specie di
denotazione
che sai possono modelli di inferenza attivi che
modellano
um framework quindi questa è questa questa
contestualizzazione del termine um in qualche modo
entra in  gioca ma ne
parleremo un po' più tardi quindi sì, grazie
fantastico e
questa è
potenzialmente una delle prime diapositive dei nostri obiettivi
perché si spera che aiuti a
tornare a questo livello
il meme
qui rappresenta questo live streaming
che riunisce
i due giornali in un modo in cui abbiamo avuto
una mano che batte le mani
ora lo riuniremo in
due puoi già sentire il suono che esce
dal live streaming soprattutto se
stai ascoltando
Dean cosa descriveresti di
ram  o come
riassumeresti oh e un'altra nota che
aggiungerò su rna ames è che vogliamo che sia
completo ma che abbia anche video
che siano ascoltabili e di
durata temporale ragionevole, quindi ci saranno molti
slide  es che avrà molto testo
copiato dal foglio e si limiterà a
mettere in pausa il video se desideri
leggere, ma andremo semplicemente avanti
da molte delle diapositive di testo che
volevamo davvero assicurarci che  tutto il
testo era invisibile ma
non leggeremo tutto quindi per
favore dean uh riassumi di cosa di questi
obiettivi vorresti
parlare sai
parlerò solo del tipo
di radice di ciascuno  uno di questi proiettili
che è dare un'occhiata più da vicino allo
strumento del realismo strumentalismo
dibattito non devo entrare in cosa
sia se ne hai partecipato
sai cosa stiamo descrivendo
uh rafforzare un approccio a due occhi aperti
dove un occhio prende nella coppia di
documenti di inferenza attiva
la condizione sociale dinamica inattiva
e il rapimento mentre l'altro uomo se l'
altro occhio manifesta inferenze attive
come integratore di entrambi
perché pensiamo che possa effettivamente
farlo senza
fondersi può effettivamente causare un  tessere o a  braid
e quindi il terzo punto è
esplicitare l'assoluta necessità se
faremo quelle prime due cose di
comprendere la profondità temporale dei
modelli che incorporerebbero effettivamente
due documenti di argomenti apparentemente distanti
mentre facciamo l'inferenza attiva in
due argomenti diversi
e  quindi quello che abbiamo fatto è stato tirare fuori
diverse
cose che gli autori hanno notato sui
loro articoli
grazie e stephen se potessi continuare
a leggere tra questi obiettivi
o aggiungere qualsiasi cosa vorresti da questa
diapositiva
sì grazie daniel quindi
ne conosci uno  serie di autori dice che
sai che sta davvero guardando allo
strumentalismo
e sai che sai che è una
prospettiva scientifica valida ma sai
che c'è poi descrive conosci
questa domanda sulla strada verso il
realismo
e il normalismo quindi
sai dov'è
l'idea che in
un documento che è lo strumentalismo è
il modo per
catturare o
per trattenerci bene in questo
lavoro scientifico
che può  essere sfidato
e vorremmo vedere i modi in cui
potremmo aver bisogno
di allentarlo quando entriamo in
approcci partecipativi, quindi qualcosa nel
mezzo che allenta quello
spazio scientifico ed è uno spazio di pratica, quindi lo
stesso con il secondo punto
um
dove va bene è  strumentalismo
um tu conosci la strada da seguire quindi cosa
costituisce i
comportamenti quando si vive in una nicchia cosa
costituisce gli esseri viventi
e come si risolve
quale strada da seguire quindi se ci
sono contraddizioni
dovremmo riconciliarle se siamo in una
squadra che cerca di  usa questo
um dovremmo semplicemente vivere con loro
e andare avanti
um o dove dovremmo effettivamente
evidenziarli, quindi questo è in un modo cercando di pensare
in un um al di fuori forse di questa sorta di
focalizzazione laser
sul
punto filosofico scientifico e dicendo ok quando
stiamo cercando di portarli in un
contesto di squadra
se dovessimo allentare un po' di quello
così
e così solo qui menzionato per
fornire un'applicazione dovremmo anche
pensare a  per quanto riguarda le
impronte attive precedute o con
suffisso sai influenza attiva adattiva
influenza attiva effettiva o
modellazione di inferenza attiva
sai quanto sia importante quel
chiarimento per poi
pensare anche a come il
pezzo di realismo strumentale potrebbe essere utilizzato in
questi altri
modi dobbiamo posizionare  ehm
, conosci completamente l'uno nell'altro
e se siamo nel mezzo
sai che
può esserci un accesso maggiore o minore alla
conoscenza in base al contesto così spesso nel
lavoro partecipativo
diversi tipi di pratiche sai che
il contesto è la chiave
e quindi questo tipo  di parla un
po' della mia idea del lavoro co-
creativo e so che um
sai che daniel è molto con i team
e i
presidi molto con la trasformazione
sai spesso c'è un
pezzo di co-creazione c'è un po' dove tu
vuoi sostenere la farfalla
senza schiacciarla c'è qualcosa di
abbastanza delicato lì,
quindi come possiamo
a volte
portarlo in spazi dove è un
c  o-spazio creativo sai dove sta
avvenendo la modellazione in un modo contestuale più sottile
e
mentre abbiamo queste
definizioni scientifiche e
progetti strategici e analisi approfondite
e sono utili, non vogliamo che
distruggano quello che sta succedendo
e ci sono un paio di  le immagini lì
che in
qualche modo parlano di quello e lo
passerò al preside forse e tu puoi parlare
al campionamento
delle acque in mezzo e alla mente il
divario
bene penso
che sia stata una bella spiegazione e
penso
quando se e  quando gli autori saranno in grado di intervenire
, sarà qualcosa a cui
ora saremo in grado di dare un po' di colore penso
che abbiamo penso che abbiamo messo delle ancore nel
terreno ma non abbiamo detto
quanto flusso
può passare tra quei diversi nodi ed è
quello che penso che volessimo
stabilire proprio qui è il travaglio
molte volte
come dice mente il divario che è l'
unica cosa che può ucciderti in
metropolitana va
bene perché non stai prestando
attenzione a  il g  p e penso che il
campionamento delle acque intermedie faccia
la stessa cosa tranne per il fatto che fornisce una
piccola
differenza sottile in termini di
fluidità di quel tipo di lacune, quindi
penso che sarebbe davvero interessante
se lo usiamo come nostro portale  nel modo in
cui potremmo mettere insieme le cose e
farle
ballare quando altrimenti sarebbero
seduti su sedie sul lato
opposto della stanza, potrebbe essere una
conversazione interessante da iniziare dal punto uno e
due
grazie a entrambi e l'unico commento che farò
aggiungi qui
questa discussione che abbiamo avuto sugli
aggettivi che precedono
l'inferenza attiva adattiva affettiva ecc.
e poi anche stephen l'attenzione che hai
portato al suffisso che x e
parentesi il
modello di inferenza attiva come un'istanza
o caso o realizzazione
inferenza attiva  struttura
teoria del processo di inferenza attiva cosa
segue e questo mi ricorda davvero le clausole di
ramificazione sinistra e diramazione destra
in grammatica e sintassi
e che c'è una base c  lause
qual è la nostra clausola di base e poi quali
ramificazioni prima durante e dopo penso che
ci sia uno spazio molto ricco e mi
piacciono molto queste
metafore incarnate e basate sul flusso che ci aiutano a
capire um
così tanto che
nelle panoramiche della carta
questi saranno solo alcuni metadati e
descrizioni sui documenti prima di
tornare allo sfondo nel contesto
e poi andare avanti nei documenti
scorrendo i loro punti principali in
modo da non leggere gli
abstract sono
entrambi ovviamente disponibili per questi articoli
ecco l'abstract per
inferenza attiva e abduzione
cognizione sociale dinamica inattiva e inferenza attiva
ecco le parole chiave per entrambi questi
articoli il documento inattivo
ha le parole chiave cognizione sociale
costruzione di nicchia
inferenza attiva teoria della mente e
attivismo e teoria dei sistemi dinamici
il documento di abduzione ha il  parole chiave
abduzione inferenza attiva
principio di energia libera prima e
relazioni triadiche coperte e perforare
andiamo agli obiettivi
e alle affermazioni del
documento sul rapimento,
quindi il
preside vorrebbe coprire
uno qualsiasi degli obiettivi del documento sul rapimento,
quello che vorrei fare è solo
predire a cosa
entrambi i documenti vogliono mirare e
quello  è che vedrai una parola chiave nel
secondo punto elenco di questo che è
alleanza e poi ci sono parole
che vedrai nell'altro giornale in
cui diranno di nuovo
che vogliamo che le cose si uniscano
ma vogliamo  fai attenzione a come
descriviamo questo incontro non
vogliamo che sia percepito metaforicamente
come una fusione come un disfacimento di
due o più cose che crediamo
abbiano una
relazione associativa e quindi penso che quando
stai attraversando il  obiettivi dei due
articoli se fai un piccolo passo indietro
vedrai che gli autori
di entrambi gli articoli
stanno dando una spiegazione difficile su quale
relazione
vogliono che prestiamo attenzione e
quindi è qualcosa a cui entrambi  i giornali
condividono che è un forte impulso  asis sulla
relazione
ottimo punto ed entrambi sono
scritti in modo molto ricco e potente
e qui vediamo alleanza e fedeltà
e sicuramente ci saranno
molte discussioni in entrambi i documenti
sull'integrazione di
ontologie e set di vocabolario disparati o parzialmente correlati
e diversi pensatori diversi thread
dello sviluppo intellettuale
queste citazioni dal documento possono essere lette
e, naturalmente, sono ampliate nel
documento
ma, come ha detto il decano, l'attenzione di questo articolo è
sull'alleanza intellettuale
tra l'inferenza attiva e il principio dell'energia libera
fep e principalmente il lavoro di
cs pierce
in termini di  semiotica pragmatica
grammaticismo logica abduttiva che è lo
scopo sintesi è riunire quei due
in un modo che è sinergico
e fornisce significato stephen
sì e solo seguendo quello
che stai dicendo entrambi questi documenti e in
particolare quello abduttivo
dà un modo  per guardare le
aree che sono davvero difficili da
simulare per i computer ehm e
il modo in cui avviene il rapimento o in
particolare con gli esseri umani è
molto sofisticato e penso
che sia davvero utile vedere la
semiotica che in realtà è molto usata
nell'ecografia teatrale e nella scenografia
um pragmatismo quindi portato in questo con
un con un con un davvero
una teoria  questo è lo sai trascende la
scienza spesso giusto è spesso usato in
altri campi come
le scienze naturali hanno una qualche utilità
ma è spesso usato nelle scienze umane
quindi penso che
questo stia parlando a quel pezzo su
cos'è che
è stato rivelato quel tipo di salsa segreta
quel tipo di colpo nell'anima che
normalmente manca e in azione
c'è anche qualcosa che è come le
fantastiche
affermazioni del giornale
sono in tutto il giornale, ma solo per
evidenziare alcune delle affermazioni chiave
stanno affermando che quell'obiettivo si erano
prefissati
tra il lavoro di inferenza attiva e
l'abduzione e la prospettiva semiotica
sembra che stiano affermando che ciò è
fattibile e che stanno fornendo
un'iniziale  schizzo per esso
in questa integrazione teorica teorica
del nuovo e del vecchio
qualcosa di rosso qualcosa di blu qualcosa di
nuovo qualcosa di vecchio
e le due strutture, rispettivamente il nuovo e il
vecchio,
sono le moderne istanze delle
neuroscienze e delle scienze cognitive
rappresentate da un principio di energia libera
e sul  vecchio un'interpretazione storicamente accurata
e precisa dell'inferenza abduttiva
inclusa l'importanza
dell'economia della ricerca tutte le cose su cui
torneremo volevo
solo chiarire le affermazioni lì posso solo
aggiungerne uno sì per
favore veloce così integrazione teorica
lì i  intendo da cosa se potessi
ripensare a quando stavamo parlando dei nostri
obiettivi
ora la domanda è questo è ciò che gli
autori stanno dicendo
quello che ci stiamo chiedendo è che rende l'
inferenza attiva sia il
prodotto di integrazione che l'integratore il processo
e di nuovo i  voglio, in qualche modo,
tornare indietro di un passo perché penso
che accadrà di nuovo quando
guarderemo  nell'altro
giornale useranno una nomenclatura diversa
ma diranno la stessa cosa e di
nuovo è difficile vedere i punti in comune a
meno che tu e tu non debba inventarli
,
devi solo
notarli
nel  due diversi tipi di foreste
e un punto sul fatto che stanno
entrambi usando l'inferenza attiva
come integratore e
differenziatore stiamo creando un
modello integrato di stati interni
ed esterni e di copertura
differenziandoli e quindi
ovviamente integrazione  e la differenziazione
hanno anche un
uso congiunto in matematica con l'integrale
e la notazione derivata, quindi
ci saranno molte cose che si
uniscono um
steven hai ancora le mani in alto sì per favore
sì solo una cosa penso
sia davvero utile parlarne
neuroscienze in questa
neuroscienza computazionale e per metterlo in evidenza
perché penso
qualcosa che
è la realtà nel mondo là fuori
la cultura là fuori
dove sono queste idee  circolando è
che la neuroscienza
è capovolta fondamentalmente
dall'influenza attiva della
neuroscienza come campo in
quanto le persone capiscono che
è
una sorta di
processo deduttivo di cose che entrano e poi
vengono valutate e
concretizzate in opposizione a questo
viaggio predittivo quindi penso che sia
davvero molto utile
perché questo è qualcosa che
tutti dobbiamo affrontare e penso che quello che ho
notato anche quando ho parlato con alcuni
neuroscienziati è che in realtà hanno
avuto una crisi esistenziale e si sono spostati in
parte spesso presentando
affermazioni inattive e vedendo davvero se
ci sono affermazioni inattive come può il loro lavoro con le
neuroscienze essere
così tenuto insieme quindi
c'è questo c'è un pezzo
qui che si riferisce al generale e
che quel
pezzo generale è più importante
quando iniziamo a portare
un'influenza attiva fuori dalle
aree specialistiche  dove è una specie di
enclave e le sue regole del gioco sono
note e sei nelle aree in cui la
gente dice bene le neuroscienze  so
cosa significa
e vai via quindi grazie mille grazie
il documento ha relativamente poche
sezioni ha
un'introduzione quindi presenta
un abbinamento
di inferenza attiva alla luce
dell'abduzione
abduzione alla luce dell'inferenza attiva
riferimento leggermente obliquo a nulla in
la biologia ha senso se non alla luce
dell'evoluzione o se non alla luce di
qualcosa e queste sono due luci per
tornare a quelle isole qual è lo spazio in
mezzo
e poi c'è una discussione
sull'economia della ricerca e la sua
naturalizzazione a energia libera e la conclusione
e il  perforare le tane del coniglio, correre in profondità, ne
parleremo presto
sul documento inattivo,
quindi qui descriveremo le
affermazioni di ames e la tabella di marcia della
cognizione sociale dinamica inattiva e il
documento di inferenza attiva
il documento presenta un due-  piegare l'obiettivo
di sezionare nuovi resoconti
che si fondono nell'attivismo con
resoconti inferenziali e spiegare perché ciò
comporta una contraddizione
è il primo obiettivo
e il se  cond obiettivo è quello di offrire
l'unico account ragionevole che collega in
attivismo e account inferenziali,
specialmente su questo caso di cognizione sociale,
quindi
sì per favore no indovina cosa speravo
potresti ora trasformare la parola collegamento in
viola per noi
sì
grazie
abbiamo diversi modi di  descrivendo il
mezzo che Stephen ha fatto un bel lavoro
di enfatizzare prima che
iniziassimo effettivamente a guardare
i giornali stessi
sì è nel mezzo sì
è fantastico ed è in realtà
attraverso la tua richiesta e la
piattaforma di diapositive che diventa uno
stigmatismo sociale dinamico attivo
e così via
questa è una prova concettuale per cosa,
ma questo è lo scopo di questo articolo ok,
hanno anche molte affermazioni
articolate durante la discussione
e in realtà usano alcune notazioni molto chiare
per descrivere le affermazioni specifiche
di altri lavori e del loro stesso lavoro
e su quali affermazioni  e le ipotesi
hanno quale relazione
logica faranno affermazioni sulla
natura della cognizione e della sua
base incarnata discuteranno alcune
delle affermazioni relative alla nicchia cognitiva sociale umana
e parleranno dell'importanza della costruzione di una
nicchia di inculturazione delle relazioni
e poi parleranno
della teoria della mente
e della compatibilità o
contraddizione
associati al collegamento di
affermazioni inattive con
teoria della mente o resoconti inferenziali,
la tabella di marcia del documento
espone molti di questi obiettivi e
afferma abbastanza chiaramente che iniziano con un'introduzione
e introducono un lavoro
recente ma influente nel
campo dell'inferenza attiva che è la struttura del
pensiero attraverso altre menti
ttom e, come si suol dire, analizzano questo
resoconto
per cercare di sviscerare il modo in cui, a
loro avviso,
i conteggi inattivi e inferenziali
sono stati messi insieme,
hanno anche una figura che descrive una
coperta di markov che sarà un
concetto che gioca molto bene in entrambi  dei
loro documenti
sezione 2 qualcosa deve dare
rifiutando l'inferenza inattiva t  attraverso
altre
menti utilizzeranno due presupposti,
vale a dire che la cognizione sociale si riduce a
rappresentazione mentale e due che
la cognizione sociale è cablata dalla nascita
e non saranno d'accordo con
entrambi questi presupposti e nella loro
opposizione a questi presupposti
supportati da subclaims  e prove
che li condurranno alle loro
conclusioni più ampie
useranno la
teoria dei sistemi dinamici
e parleranno di come dst
può essere collegato a un attivismo in termini
di compatibilità e cosa questi due
framework si offrono l'un l'altro all'interno di una
lettura strumentale
e  quindi discuteranno l'
inferenza attiva specificamente nel contesto della
teoria dei sistemi dinamici da un lato e della
cognizione sociale inattiva
dall'altro, questa è la sillabazione dinamica inattiva
che descriveranno con alcune cifre
sulle somiglianze e le differenze
tra l'inazione sociale in generale  come
concettualizzato al di fuori dell'inferenza attiva
e poi lo sono
introdurranno visivamente come l'inferenza attiva
arricchisca quell'immagine
e poi hanno una tabella molto interessante che
distingue tra o tra i
fenomeni osservati nel mondo naturale
e il comportamento osservato nel mondo naturale
ok
fantastico scorrere le carte in questo
modo
ora
passiamo al  sezione background in context
quindi in questa sezione del punto
zero
useremo sicuramente alcune citazioni dal documento,
ma faremo anche un passo indietro
e dimostreremo solo la punta
dell'iceberg della borsa di studio e della
ricerca  che abbiamo condotto fino
a questo punto, si
spera per eccitare
l'ascoltatore o il lettore
e per fornire un contesto in questi
thread molto profondi che verranno
affrontati e approssimati nei
documenti fornirò una prima nota qui o dean per
favore vai per  è
solo che penso che questo sia un
momento spettacolare per dire
ok, quindi
sfondo e contesto quindi stiamo parlando
forse
dell'impostazione temporale e
fisica,
quindi tha  Ora è qualcosa che possiamo
analizzare situazionalmente
e ancora
una volta non importa se usi l'
inferenza attiva o se usi un
modello cast o se usi
iniziative professionali che programmano la
linea di fondo è che tutti stanno cercando di
capire
qual è la situazione
attraverso un'analisi  metodo e e
e e immagino che ognuno di questi
metodi
abbia una fattibilità maggiore o minore a
seconda di quale sia la situazione sia
temporalmente che fisicamente
quindi penso
che siano le cose critiche che non stiamo
dicendo che ognuno di questi documenti
sia buono o cattivo
stiamo dicendo che ciascuno di questi documenti
si concentra su una
combinazione di contesto di sfondo diversa minimo
di due, quindi ora se mettiamo insieme le due cose
non possiamo dire
che sarà la stessa
cosa che faremo  escogitiamo
i nostri obiettivi come persone che ora
hanno guardato i due documenti uno accanto all'altro
che creerà un'entità completamente nuova
grazie
per portare fuori questo sfondo e
contesto  sezione tualizzando volevo
invocare uno dei miei poeti artigiani preferiti
william blake
e blake hanno scritto i
contrari sono positivi una negazione
non è un contrario le
negazioni non sono contrarie i contrari
esistono reciprocamente
ma esistono negazioni non esistono
eccezioni e obiezioni e incredulità
non esistono né saranno mai
organizzate  i contrari della citazione per sempre e per sempre
in questo
quadruplice quadro logico blakeyiano
in effetti
fanno parte di una dialettica ed esistono
in funzione l'uno dell'altro come convessi
e concavi o come gravità e
radiazione come potrebbe portarlo Buckminster Fuller
e quindi negazioni in questo poetico
quadro
sono quelli che
non esistono
mentre a e b possono essere al contrario
mentre a e non a hanno una
relazione logica diversa e questo tipo di
approccio logico quadruplo
al riconoscimento dello spazio degli stati e della
verità afferma che più
asserzioni giustapposte possono avere con
tra di loro
è previsto anche in molte
tradizioni della conoscenza mondiale
um fo  ad esempio il kata scotty
e questo è uno
strumento logico e un metodo che è stato applicato
per molto tempo nelle tradizioni dharmiche
del contesto indiano
volevano fornirlo e anche
con queste immagini che ognuno di voi
è il benvenuto per esplorare
cosa  una mano che batte le mani o una persona che
fa le divisioni
ha a che fare con la contraddizione e la
negazione
sì decano sì anche per
quanto riguarda la contraddizione e
penso che questo
indichi
il tipo di pezzo contestuale
um
il
pezzo di analisi situazionale
c'è c'è la situazione
all'interno della quale
ci sono ci sono le
contraddizioni sono costruite se questo
ha un senso
um e questo è anche incarnato e messo
in atto attraverso la nostra vita quindi potrebbe benissimo essere
da bambino lo sai
la morfologia del bambino in
fasi diverse in contesti diversi dà il
modo
di
stabilire la situazione
consapevolezza
e le contraddizioni all'interno di ciò,
man mano che le cose vengono codificate, quindi hai
queste queste
queste situazionali
ehm
i processi sono una specie di um sono ciò che stiamo
facendo in questo flusso di modellizzazione in corso il
tipo di campi di pratica
in questi diversi documenti che
li sostengono l'inattivista sente una pratica
o um i campi di pratica più computazionali
che hanno sono  ciò che
incarniamo e in cui entriamo e impariamo
ed è quello che stiamo
modellando intuitivamente in un modo in cui abbiamo
un'idea di come dovremmo modellare essere
in queste situazioni le contraddizioni
ma che modellare
spesso e questo è il pericolo
quando  viene
sopraffatto da qualcuno con il proprio modello, ad
es.
qualcuno nel suo mondo sta
modellando com'è essere se stessi o cercando di
elaborarlo, vanno a vedere un consulente
con il loro modello e quel modello
viene utilizzato per adattarli al modello
e poi quel consulente  ci dirà
qual è il loro problema come è inquadrato,
quindi penso che questo modello in
um sia
abbastanza rilevante qui perché sai che
una volta stabilite queste contraddizioni
potrebbe benissimo
esserci un mo  del creato all'interno di quel
dominio
e quindi qualcuno che non è necessariamente
in quel dominio
può
essere ascritto al modello non sanno
qual è il gioco non sono nel
processo e il modello prende il sopravvento, quindi quel
tipo di passaggio alle divisioni
perché allora ok abbiamo due cose
stanno insieme
stiamo parlando di questo sì
ti apriamo e hai una posizione
ok quindi sono leggermente e ad un certo punto
è come se non fosse una posizione fratello
che è  questa è una divisione in cui sei entrato
lì devi stare attento,
quindi sei entrato in questa idea che
stai aprendo le cose ora erano
una cosa da cui iniziare erano una
posizione su cui erano tenuti  in un certo senso
si sono divisi in un modo in
cui ora sono
isolati l'uno dall'altro, sai,
suppongo che stiamo cercando di trovare un
modo per non spingerli in uno
né per averli separati, forse abbiamo una posizione
in mezzo a
quello  è in qualche modo agile e
in questo caso si riferisce al realismo e
all'ins  strumentalismo che in qualche modo riecheggia alcuni
temi più ampi
grazie preside
solo molto veloce um molte persone hanno
sentito il baronismo yogi di quando vedi
un bivio sulla strada
prendilo e so che con
molto il termine giunto
è arrivato  ad esempio, aumenta molto la probabilità congiunta
e quindi l'idea di dividere qui
è davvero buona per
parlare metaforicamente perché
se stai
guardando qualcosa con
interferenza attiva e stai presumendo che
in un esperimento di labirinto del tè devi andare bene a
sinistra o a destra  gli esseri umani
possono vedere un bivio sulla strada e prenderlo
è una specie di scherzo in piedi
se vedi un bivio nelle mie gambe prendili
non
necessariamente devi scegliere un'ape puoi
prendere tutto e penso che sia quello che
blake  sta cercando di indicare questo
esercizio e quindi è una contraddizione
no se vedo un utensile sulla strada posso
portarlo ma se non sono
aperto all'idea che fork non significhi solo
sinistra o destra,
allora sono  già autolimitante in termini
di wh  mentre sto testando ciò che sono
analizzato situazionalmente
grazie a entrambi bene nelle
parti di parole chiave più dirette
quindi in azione dal
sito thisdefinitions.net un'azione è uno dei modi possibili
per organizzare la conoscenza e le
forme di interazione con il mondo
conoscenza inattiva  è la conoscenza che
deriva dall'azione ed è costruita
su abilità motorie come manipolare
oggetti andando in bicicletta o praticare uno
sport che è solo una delle tante
definizioni che sono state fornite
abbiamo anche avuto diversi live streaming e
discussioni su carta su un'azione in inferenza attiva
per esempio
nel live streaming attivo numero sei nel
lontano 2020 quando nel 2020 abbiamo discusso di
ramstead una storia di due densità l'
inferenza attiva è un'inferenza attiva
nel
2021 abbiamo discusso di un articolo anche di
hippolyto in tutte le prestazioni abili incarnate in
cui l'azione è
e interessante
per  saggiando in qualche modo questa stessa
discussione ecco una diapositiva da
quel live streaming
con uh del giornale hippolyto
e  qui avevamo la
triade penetrante e avevamo il simbolismo e
questo la semiotica e i riferimenti al
francese,
quindi in realtà stavamo parlando del
concetto molto correlato di rappresentazione
e in effetti di coloro che supportano
e o rifiutano e o trovano contraddizione
e collegano tutti i  sopra
la discussione
sull'inattivismo e il
resoconto inferenziale dipenderà molto dalla
questione della rappresentazione e delle rappresentazioni cognitive
cosa sono dove o
se esistono e così via
um che era livestream 23.
anche da questo articolo di sangati per niente
uh loro  disponiamo solo
visivamente vedremo presto più rappresentazioni
dal loro punto
di vista alcune delle distinzioni tra
cognizione sociale tradizionale
e cognizione sociale inattiva
e quindi piuttosto che solo un'interpretazione visiva
del nome dell'immagine ritengo
che vorresti fornirlo
no aspetto di  nel prossimo va bene,
quindi qui quello che vedo è che nei
tradizionali conti inferenziali cognitivi sociali
gli ingranaggi  girano all'interno del cervello
e poi ci sono circuiti di azione percettiva
e collegamenti che collegano le
entità sociali che sono nel loro corpo ma il
corpo è visto come un'interfaccia
per quel tipo di informazioni trasferisce
una posizione estrema o una semplice rappresentazione visiva
e quindi qui in contrasto noi  vedere come
gli ingranaggi siano ovunque, incluso
nell'ambiente nella nicchia nello
spazio intermedio
e che sì il cervello sta facendo le cose
ma fa anche parte di un sistema attuato
che sta implementando questo
processo cognitivo sociale inculturato un po' di
più in una cornice olistica, quindi  dean si si
stavo solo per dire
tra un minuto che vedremo di
cosa parla il rapimento, ma per
ora vorrei che le persone tenesse
in mente l'idea che
si tratta di un tipo di
profondità temporale ma quella profondità temporale è
verticale penso che l'abduzione guardando linee temporali più lunghe
per centinaia di anni sia più
orizzontale quindi tieni presente che
siamo tal  re profondità temporale ma il
focus è su una profondità temporale verticale o profonda
invece di un'ampia profondità temporale laterale
entrambi contano ma sono ortogonali
non significa che siano in
conflitto tra loro significa solo che stanno
andando  in direzioni diverse questo è tutto ciò che
voglio dire
è divertente sinistra e destra o ovest e
est quelle sono direzioni opposte ma
non sono direzioni negative e quindi
proprio lì è dove iniziamo a vedere
come l'ortogonalità o la scarsità
o l'indipendenza condizionale siano
concesse  da una coperta di markov per esempio
come quelli possono essere visti nel quadro
dei contrari anche se non delle negazioni
stephen
e quell'ingranaggio nel
diagramma a destra lì l'ingranaggio in mezzo
sai che può avere una profondità temporale
che può avere questo corpo-mente  il
pezzo sull'ambiente è sicuramente lì come stai
dicendo e ovviamente fa come unità di
analisi che è davvero impegnativo e
vorrei anche inserire lì come ingranaggio le parole le
parole sono
contrarie
t  la stregoneria della nostra casella vocale ci sta dando
parole nello spazio intorno a noi
così sai che vengono usate anche come strumenti
così all'improvviso
siamo molto più invischiati anche se è
solo un discorso
sì e ci vuole tempo perché il discorso
viaggi attraverso il  Internet e attraverso lo
spazio e il tempo
un po' più di approfondimento sull'inazione sociale
questa uh risorsa di ricerca sull'inazione
descrive diversi significati e sensi di
inazione
nei sensi performativo e di produzione
quindi per favore leggi
e anche un bel documento del 2009
sulla semiotica cognitiva di de bruyne  e de
haan
discutono di alcune delle relazioni di un
attivismo nella cognizione sociale
e hanno fatto un ottimo lavoro nel
riassumere ciò
che gli account inferenziali e inattivisti possono mettere
insieme e in qualche modo
discutere di quel collegamento sì per favore dean
sì ho
letto quella gente perché l'ho trovata  ed
ecco una cosa interessante
se usano una metafora del ponte
penso che un attivismo abbia un ponte
è solo un ponte verticale
è il  lato di un edificio che sale
e quindi
um
niente non per non criticare quello
che hanno scritto qui, ma penso che ci
sia un debito
e ci sia una capacità di estendersi è
solo che sta andando in
verticale, non sta andando tradizionalmente da un
lato all'altro
fantastico
quindi  per un po' di approfondimento sul
rapimento e sulla semiotica,
abbiamo fatto un bel viaggio di apprendimento
insieme
e l'
articolo sul rapimento
con
uno o uno e mezzo o anche due degli
autori che erano veri esperti di Pearson ha
fornito molti dettagli
pierce era uno scrittore e pensatore prolifico
e collaboratore e anche gran parte del
lavoro non è stato pubblicato, il che significa che
ci sono alcuni sistemi di riferimento arcani
e non tutto è iper accessibile
abbiamo trovato il sito commons.org
immensamente utile nel fornire molte
definizioni e collegamenti a
risorse che il decano avrebbe  ti piace
riassumere qualsiasi cosa in questa pagina
nient'altro che se
tu se sei interessato al
pragmatismo e vuoi superare
william james in realtà william  james e
charles sanders pierce avevano un po'
come erano forse 150 anni fa
i primi
conflitti su come funzionano le
cose, in realtà è davvero un incredibile
punto di decollo in termini di come le persone che
sembrano essere in competizione tra
loro effettivamente fanno  l'un l'altro
più intelligenti, ma in realtà molte delle cose,
molte delle idee su cui 150 anni
dopo stiamo ora guardando indietro,
dovremmo dire che potrebbero sentirsi in
competizione tra loro ma penso
che quello che stavano facendo fosse trasmettere  o in
qualche modo costruendo un modello migliore perché
non guardavano sempre le cose perché
con gli stessi occhi avevano entrambi gli occhi
aperti, quindi dirò solo vai
sul sito comune è davvero bello
sì è fantastico questa rappresentazione
taglia ironicamente in modo
appropriato  è del noto
quadro semiotico della triade di Pearson in cui un
segnale di stop è chiamato il rappresentante
l'
istanza rappresentata il segnale di stop fisico il vero
segnale di stop
l'oggetto è il pasticcio  le macchine dell'età devono fermarsi
qui e l'interpretante è che dovrei
fermarmi qui ed è lì che otteniamo
quell'agenzia di entità
ho trovato un documento interessante
sull'interfaccia utente
che porta alcune di queste
discussioni davvero senza tempo su semiotica e
logica in un contesto digitale
che stanno applicando  quella semiosi alla
metafora dell'interfaccia utente che
si potrebbe immaginare se fosse un
segnale di stop nel mondo reale o se fosse un
pulsante su un sito Web in un contesto di interfaccia utente
e
chiunque può fermarsi e leggere alcune di
queste eccellenti selezioni da virgolette
e uh
lezioni tenute
su come le
copie, segni e simboli sono collegati
attraverso la logica e la
semiosi molto qui, ma continueremo
sull'abduzione in modo specifico, quindi questo era un
po 'sul pierce e sulla definizione
di semiotica in contrasto con
la scienza delle cose le scienze più positive
e la scienza delle forme che
sono le scienze più formali
cos'è il ragionamento abduttivo
questo è stato molto affascinante da esplorare
questa è una citazione dall'abductio  Nell'articolo che
hanno scritto è comune nella letteratura secondaria
,
ad esempio, basarsi sulla perforazione
per concepire l'abduzione come accade in
due parti o due tipi
abduzione generativa e abduzione selettiva
ecco un'altra prospettiva sui due
tipi o sulle due varietà o due
componenti motore a due tempi  di
abduzione dall'enciclopedia di Stanford
uh filosofia che
hanno scritto nella letteratura filosofica
il termine abduzione è usato in
due sensi correlati ma diversi
in entrambi i sensi il termine si riferisce al
ragionamento esplicativo
nel primo senso storicamente si
riferisce
al posto del ragionamento esplicativo nella
generazione di ipotesi  questa è
abduzione generativa mentre nel secondo
senso che è il senso più usato
nella letteratura moderna si
riferisce al posto del
ragionamento esplicativo nel giustificare o valutare un
insieme enumerato di ipotesi
e in un certo senso dà senso
al contenuto  deve essere generata per essere
curata le idee devono essere specifiche  ied
enumerato per essere giustificato o
valutato
decano per favore continua su questo
bene solo molto velocemente quindi
ora abbiamo il rosso e il blu che era
davvero molto importante evidenziare
che hai bisogno di entrambi hai bisogno di un minimo di
due perché la spiegazione
appaia
dopo abduttivo  il ragionamento in
senso probabilistico è anche noto come
inferenza alla migliore spiegazione è una
forma di ragionamento logico che guarda
all'ipotesi più probabile per spiegare
qualcosa un esempio i fagioli bianchi
nella mano sinistra provenivano dal sacchetto di
oggetti tenuto nella destra  mano qui
possiamo vedere come l'ipotesi avanzata
dipenda
da un'osservazione incompleta o da
un'inferenza ci sono fagioli anche nella
borsa e anche se è così che la fonte
di ciò che è stato trasferito alla
mano sinistra quindi di nuovo la profondità temporale
quando si arriva in  una situazione
che tipo di background e che
tipo di contesto
possiedi andrà a questa quarta forma
di logica che o borsa sembra letteralmente  Hai
passato una vita a
cercare di
districarsi e poi
riformarsi in una sorta di coerenza
e
coloro che ascoltano possono iniziare a vedere
sentori di precedenti osservazioni sensoriali
aggiornamenti posteriori delle credenze sul
mondo anche la selezione dell'azione entrare in
gioco, in particolare la traduzione delle
disponibilità di azioni istantanee in  politiche che possono
essere valutate in base alla loro energia libera attesa
, ma ci arriveremo
passiamo
al rapimento ed ecco alcuni dei
documenti molto affascinanti disponibili sui
beni comuni relativi al rapimento molto lì
e per continuare con uno
dei  risorse dai beni comuni
sull'abduzione come inferenza pratica
di thomas capitan
questo lavoro di
cui non leggeremo tutto
approfondisce molti punti interessanti
su quella doppia natura dell'abduzione
con generazione
di ipotesi e selezione di ipotesi
e distingue che la
selezione di ipotesi
può fare in modo deduttivo  valide valutazioni
comunque le fasi di creatività  e
non è inferenziale che ha molta
risonanza con idee come non pre-censurare
e avere una
discussione inclusiva durante il brainstorming
e il riconoscimento che deve esserci una
vagliatura in un periodo limitato di spazio
e tempo
inoltre c'è qualche discussione
qui
questo è stato
relazionarsi
mentre ci spostiamo indietro o ci intrecciamo
con il principio dell'energia libera
la consapevolezza iniziale dell'ipotesi
arriva con l'osservazione di un
insieme collocato per mezzo di una
visione incontrollata del mondo delle
idee in ciò che lui chiamava terzità come
dato nella percezione
il romanzo concepire qualsiasi  esempio della
premessa 2 che
cita una parte precedente dell'articolo è
causato da cognizioni precedenti il
ntenuto è suggerito dai fatti osser
azioni osservazioni sensoriali ma no
tutto ciò che è suggerito è dedotto dalla
cognizione dei fatti e qui
di pierc
prosegue descrivendo ci sono opera
ioni del  mente che sono
logicamente esattamente analoghi alle
inferenze
accettando solo che sono unc  onscious
e quindi incontrollabile e
quindi non soggetto a critiche, quindi
lasciando da parte domande come se i
processi inconsci possano essere
considerati controllabili
qui vediamo molto accenni di
percezione come inferenza inconscia e
vediamo anche continuità
tra processi di attenzione e
consapevolezza
inferenze consce
e altre inferenze inconsce  e quindi
in un certo senso questo fornisce anche un
quadro integrato della percezione
apprendimento delle credenze aggiornamento della profondità temporale
consapevolezza conscia e inconscia
tutte queste caratteristiche sono esplorate nel
lavoro persiano e il
documento sul rapimento evidenzierà in modo molto specifico
questo fatto
va bene andare avanti un po'  un po' di più
uh rapimento e retroduzione
vorresti aggiungere qualcosa su
questo preside
bene intendo le persone che lo hanno studiato e
analizzato questa
meraviglia a volte se questa fosse o meno
una
morfologia o se possiamo usare o meno
i due termini contemporaneamente o in modo
intercambiabile di
nuovo  probabilmente è uno  di quelle cose in
cui se
vuoi scoprire quali sono i dettagli
dovresti probabilmente andare a dare un'occhiata
perché è interessante ma
a questo punto non tutto ciò che fondamentalmente vogliamo
fare è
qui, mi limiterò a leggere questa
retroduzione del  processo per cui
dalla sorprendente serie di fatti siamo condotti
a
una congettura abbiamo usato molto la congettura
teoria per spiegarli molti
logici si rifiutano di chiamare quest'ultima
inferenza
perché la sua conclusione è così estremamente
problematica da equivalere a poco più
di un interrogatorio
sono sicuro che si sbagliano tuttavia non si
sono
impossessati della vera
definizione scientifica di inferenza quindi quello che sta
dicendo fondamentalmente qui è non
chiamiamo
ragionamento abduttivo ragionamento induttivo infrarosso
la giustificazione logica di una
retroduzione di cui la giusta
conclusione è che il  lo stato
di cose congetturato è probabile
nel senso vago di tendere
ad assomigliare allo
stato di cose reale e questa è la parte in
cui così wh  at sostituisce quello
strumentalismo
qualunque cosa definiamo come
questo è di nuovo
questo è uno di quegli enigmi se non lo
è se non
è lo stato reale è quello che non è allora cos'è uno stato
irreale o non reale perché è
lì
che abbiamo  etichettato
ciò che cosa riempie che cosa si sente che
alla fine per fare il tutto questa è la
domanda qui
e anche di nuovo vale la pena leggere alcuni
dei lavori precedenti di uno degli autori
dell'articolo sul rapimento e si può vedere
nella loro ricerca una forte linea di
sviluppo e  estendere e
modernizzare gran parte del
lavoro,
allora sì, quindi ho messo giù quei segni dell'orso
perché voglio raccontare una
storia davvero molto veloce
quindi se vivi da qualche parte dove ci sono gli
orsi se il segno dell'orso rimane in piedi le
persone iniziano a ignorare il  oggetto segno reale
e non diventano più
interpreti perdono volontariamente
quel triadico quindi
se ti occupi di
benessere animale e non vuoi che gli orsi si
abituino troppo
uomo contatto devi essere
molto selettivo quando metti l'iscrizione
e, soprattutto, quando rimuovi il
segno,
quindi volevo metterlo lì perché
questa è una parte importante del pezzo abduttivo e di
retroduzione è
che a volte devi portare via le cose
per cui  il rapimento per lavorare è la rimozione
delle possibilità
che in realtà
crea
un'enfasi penso che continueremo semplicemente al realismo
e allo strumentalismo perché
torneremo al rapimento nelle
discussioni successive, quindi
ecco alcune citazioni da un documento di fair bend
secondo il realismo tale conoscenza
la conoscenza fattuale è descrittiva di
caratteristiche generali o particolari
dell'universo, quindi ciò non significa che il
modello di gravità sia la gravità non significa
che il modello di gravità sia ciò che sono gli
oggetti di gravità
ma un realista lo farebbe  osserva che per
esempio i modelli formali di gravità
ci insegnano l'esistenza di
oggetti su cui agisce la forza di gravità
e autorizzano la descrizione di una forza
che può  non essere visto direttamente sentito o
sentito ma ha comunque un'influenza notevole le
forze sono cose reali sono reali
secondo lo strumentalismo
anche una teoria che è del tutto corretta
non descrive nulla ma serve
come strumento per la previsione dei
fatti che ne costituiscono il contenuto empirico
e così  ancora sull'esempio di
gravitazione di questo newton gli strumentisti
potrebbero ritenere che non ci siano
entità
forza gravitazionale e campi gravitazionali
sono semplicemente applicazioni strumentali
di
argomenti statistici o potenzialmente anche argomenti sociali o
dinamici di potere
e uno strumentista può negare l'
esistenza di oggetti
entità e forze in questo  caso
e persino portare le cose al livello di
avere scetticismo sulle parole come
strumenti e sulle relazioni intorno alla
comunicazione
e su come ordina e prevede i dati sensoriali
abbiamo esplorato molto il realismo e lo
strumentalismo durante i
flussi e abbiamo evidenziato molto nel
lavoro di mel andrews  nel numero di streaming live  14.
un'altra diapositiva su realismo e
strumentalismo e poi uno di voi per
favore si senta libero
um descriverò di nuovo alcuni degli ultimi
la distinzione del territorio della mappa è
molto
chiave per la conversazione di realismo e strumentalismo
c'è stata anche una varietà di eccellente
lavoro filosofico
per  esempio un successore del realismo
anti-realismo interroga
quelli due tra l'altro direi che sono
negazioni mentre realismo e
strumentalismo
che stiamo suggerendo potrebbero essere visti come
contrari
e anche il lavoro di Helen Longano sul
pluralismo scientifico ha molto da dire
su questo prendendo un
obiettivo multidisciplinare sul realismo e lo
strumentalismo
e poi il preside vorresti descrivere
qualcosa di questo articolo di prim'ordine che hai trovato
uh potrei non ricordarlo nei
grandi schemi ad essere onesti è qui per la
gente da leggere c'erano molti giornali
e  ancora una volta stiamo solo mettendo un sacco di
testo per coloro che vogliono fermarsi e
seguire i sentieri
e tutto viene invischiato in
stephen an  y commenti sul realismo
strumentalismo suppongo che il pezzo che mi
viene in mente molto è che
tutto questo è poi
sostenuto dall'azione a un certo livello, quindi
l'idea di cercare
um diverse
contraddizioni o diversi approcci um
retrò
potrebbe essere un caso  di te immagina
quando qualcuno pensa di intraprendere un percorso
attraverso i boschi
che conosci o potresti reincarnare molte di
queste cose
o e forse tutto a un certo livello
sta attraversando
un'incarnazione e quando è concettuale che l'
incarnazione sta accadendo solo in  uno
spazio più concettuale,
ehm, che non si basa su tanti altri
tipi di storie o su come
ti senti attraverso le cose,
quindi
la differenza che succede quando sei
in un campo di pratica è che sei così
abituato a esserci  campo di pratica
che
quell'incarnazione diventi l'acqua in
cui nuoti in
modo che potrebbe essere
qualcosa che si riferisce in qualche modo a questo
grande sì decano solo molto veloce quindi di
nuovo chiederemo a questo punto sì per
reali  sm
si allo strumentalismo
si fino alla fine
no o
annullato
abbiamo avuto una piccola e commerciale qui e
noi e qui
ehm una breve nota per e
cognizione non approfondiremo qui ma 4e può
fare riferimento a come per xiavio e van der
documento schiff 2018 che era nel
contesto della pedagogia musicale che è
un'area molto affascinante 4e è incarnato
incorporato incorporato
esteso emanato
inculturato ecc ecc ecc 7e 11e 22e
tutti e poi una citazione divertente di Carl
Fristen
dal nostro
simposio sull'inferenza attiva applicata nel
ha detto che una cosa fondamentale sull'inferenza attiva
è che è oltre l'
elaborazione predittiva è oltre la senzienza e
sottolinea o riflette la
svolta pragmatica all'inizio di questo secolo
davvero incarnata dalle quattro e
per chiarire che la senzienza è
attiva
e che stai parlando
sulla causalità circolare dell'impegno
con qualsiasi particella personale o vegetale con
qualunque cosa c'è là fuori causalità circolare viola
e tutto ciò implica
quindi piuttosto breve  Solo che non entreremo
in nessuno di questi dettagli, ma ecco un
mucchio di lavori che sono rilevanti per il
documento inattivo,
solo alcune delle altre
citazioni di sfondo e altri lavori che si potrebbero
voler esaminare
e per il documento abduttivo
e anche un  un po' di sporgersi anche
in qualcosa, si spera che gli autori possano
spiegarci il ruolo e la
relazione del nominalismo con tutto
questo, ma molti articoli precedenti degli
autori qui
elencati e un sacco di ottimo lavoro di nuovo quindi
grazie ragazzi per
questo viaggio
ora
possiamo entrare nei due fogli o nello
spazio in mezzo
facciamo una giustapposizione iniziale
dei due fogli metto il nostro video qui
sarà la punta dell'iceberg quindi preside
tu sei la punta dell'iceberg
cosa vorresti dire  su questi due documenti
in una giustapposizione iniziale,
come ho detto, penso che
se davvero fai un passo indietro e ti rendi conto
che ciò che le persone stanno
facendo accoppiando all'inferenza attiva
stai dicendo che
ho un tipo particolare  di
analisi situazionale che
vorrei eseguire e così facendo
vorrei provare a rimuovere le contraddizioni o
vorrei
formulare integrazioni
e se fai un passo indietro in quel posto
il
tuo esempio di così il tuo iper il tuo
iper um la
tua testa la tua  l'argomento è sub uh
analisi situazionale il tuo esempio si
adatta al fatto che
ora non stai commettendo
l'errore di dire che il
mio modo di farlo guardare le cose
nega automaticamente o trasforma in polvere altri
modi di guardare tutto ciò che è
sotto quel titolo un'analisi situazionale
ora
ci sono confronti e non sono
scritti qui e sono così pronti che
ho semplicemente scelto esempi all'interno di
ciascuno dei documenti in cui i
documenti parlano di due diversi
punti focali ma sono ancora all'interno di
questo confine marginale più ampio e più ampio
di attivo  inferenza e come
si comporta
l'inferenza attiva intorno al comportamento
all'interno di un regime di attenzione e
aprendolo a qualcosa di più disponibile rispetto
al  i dettagli o la cosa amichevole della scala
della teoria della mente si fondono necessariamente
con l'inferenza attiva
o l'idea che l'abduzione nel momento in
cui arrivo in realtà
nega qualsiasi possibilità di usare
strumenti per estendere la mia finestra sensoriale
proprio così di nuovo non abbiamo intenzione di spendere
un sacco di tempo per
tirare fuori queste altre cose, ma se le
persone vogliono davvero vedere come quando
metti circa due fogli uno accanto
all'altro puoi trovare un sacco di
somiglianze
è un esercizio interessante ci
vuole un po'
ma quando li vedi davvero  fianco a fianco
e aggrovigliato c'è un c'è un
sacco di trecce in corso
grazie dean stephen
sì mi piace questo ehm
come se parlasse dean lì
hai questi due documenti potrebbero quasi essere
visti come due iceberg in cui
le loro filosofie sono gentili  di
congelato e ha
dato forma e forma e c'è roba
sotto e roba sopra
ma c'è anche l'acqua in
mezzo alla
quale potrebbe esserci un
sacco di gamberetti e  e ogni sorta di
cose che nuotano in giro
quindi penso che in questa lista qui in cui
hai un po' di realismo
strumentalismo beh, sono i tuoi due
iceberg giusto
, vogliamo che siano simpatici e affilati
e forse vieni colpito un po' se
sbatti  fuori di loro e poi ok statistiche
e confronto dei modelli
sai
che sono ancora là fuori
ma potrebbero scherzare un po '
comunicazione delle convinzioni multi-agente oh aspetta
abbiamo qualcosa che scorre qui
cose come insiemi assemblati scusa
modelli come prospettiva degli insiemi
o prospettiva dei collant o dove sono quelle
prospettive che provengono dai modi di conoscere
i sistemi complessi della stocasticità
e così via
um
siamo ora forse
non so se non stiamo dissolvendo
l'iceberg non si tratta che l'
iceberg è lì ma siamo  sono
diversi tipi di
modi e
di iniziare a essere forse più flessibili
e meno stabili
fantastici quindi nel documento inattivo andiamo in
modo da mantenere le cose ragionevoli e
avere anche molto da discutere in quello  e
ancora due, inseriamo molto contenuto nelle
diapositive per metterti in pausa e goderti la
maggior parte del contenuto viene copiato e citato
dal foglio, quindi questo è il punto di
riferimento per saperne di più
che analizzeremo
nell'ordine della tabella di marcia  alcuni dei
pezzi chiave che i giornali esaminano, quindi
nella sezione uno del documento inattivo
inizieranno con una
sintesi
dell'argomento di Vessier at all 2020 per
comprendere gli altri nel mondo e
che è presentato in questo modo di pensare
attraverso altre menti ttom paper  e poi
tom è la teoria della
mente riassumono
o catturano l'argomento del pensare
attraverso altre menti come
premessa una cognizione sociale è inattiva
e incarnata due inattiva e incarnata
l'attore sociale non può afferrare direttamente
la cognizione sociale
tre tutto ciò che non può essere
afferrato direttamente deve essere dedotto
ergo qed conclusione si
deve dedurre la cognizione sociale inattiva e incorporata
ci deve essere un'inferenza sulla
cognizione sociale
e gli autori della  documento inattivo
afferma che per premessa due e tre
ttom si uniscono all'ortodossia Tom, la
comprensione del mondo e degli altri a
loro si riduce alla capacità di dedurre
e attribuire stati mentali
che è la sintesi del pensiero
attraverso altre menti
e che metteranno in discussione
su questa dissezione critica che un
tale account sta davvero rendendo questo
matrimonio felice con un attivismo
che tireranno su sì chiunque
o continueranno ok lo
faranno si tireranno fuori con alcuni
diversi di  queste premesse
e quali ipotesi nascoste potrebbero essere alla
base di quelle premesse come quali
assiomi portano a generare tali
premesse
la contraddizione tra p1 e p2
risulta da due ipotesi nascoste in
quell'argomento t2m quindi qui vediamo p123
sopra
e poi ipotesi nascosta una
cognizione sociale riduce a  informazioni
in forma proposizionale esplicita
rappresentazione mentale e attribuzione
diranno questo si
sentono in questo modo come a  anche la rappresentazione mentale
e l'assunzione nascosta la
cognizione sociale è cablata con i concetti
e gli strumenti logici per l'inferenza ad
esempio
alla nascita
e nelle sezioni
successive analizzeranno e chiariranno la
contraddizione tra le premesse uno e
due
questa tensione di
se la cognizione sociale non è  t attivo e
incarnato
è davvero il caso o è
un'affermazione contraddittoria
che la cognizione sociale non può essere
colta direttamente da un tale attore sociale
, quindi valuteranno criticamente
dalla prospettiva inattiva quali
problemi potrebbero essere alla base di questi
presupposti, i presupposti nascosti e
perché  un attivista rifiuta questi presupposti nascosti
e quindi rifiuta le premesse sopra elencate
e quindi esplorerà
quali sono questi
metodi e meccanismi non rappresentativi di
co-costruzione nell'azione sociale
ha una copertura di markov
una rappresentazione visiva che abbiamo
visto qui prima
con gli stati interni gli stati esterni
e la mediazione dell'in  stati interni ed
esterni per stati di copertura
che secondo la definizione della perla 1988
sono gli stati di copertura che rendono gli
stati interni ed esterni
condizionatamente indipendenti a
volte le persone vanno oltre e descrivono
una coperta fristen in cui gli
stati di copertura b
sono suddivisi in due tipi di stati
senso e attivo
e questi due tipi di stati sono
definiti dal loro arrivo dal
punto di vista degli stati interni
dipendenze statistiche stati sensoriali
e dipendenze statistiche uscenti
che possono essere interpretate come azioni o
interfacce
dall'entità o cosa verso la nicchia,
ma torneremo alle coperte di markov
e più tardi
sì stephen provaci
solo tornando su quella in
realtà la pagina la diapositiva prima di questo,
ma in relazione a questo è quando dice che le
cose non possono essere direttamente ci sono un
paio di cose che possono essere
comprese direttamente bene direi che con
quello è un  distinzione utile perché
quando pensiamo a um stiamo
parlando della presa e  l'impugnatura o un paio di
pinze e non riesco ad afferrare direttamente un
tubo caldo ho bisogno delle pinze non posso fare direttamente
un certo numero di cose senza forse
più di uno strumento
ma c'è la sensazione che
quando parliamo di afferrare cose o
quando le persone pensano a se
qualcosa è
, sai per afferrare qualcosa
che è esplicitamente proposizionale
, sai che abbiamo altri tipi di strumenti
che potrebbero entrare in gioco anche quando
pensiamo alle parole
e all'atto di attribuire
tutte queste cose possono essere
esibizioni con  strumenti a tutti i livelli
quindi
c'è una fusione interessante in corso
qui a seconda di come
l'iceberg si scioglie alla
grande
nella sezione due
che puoi leggere nel documento o fermarti
qui e catturarne molti
aspetti metteranno in dubbio l'ipotesi
che la cognizione sociale si riduce a rappresentazione mentale
e il
loro punto può essere distillato in quanto
comprendere gli altri è una questione di
essere abili nel condividere significati non espliciti
e potenzialmente in qualche modo
abduttivo
ding-ding-ding e ragionamento basato su modelli,
che sono tutti
modificabili e dinamici in base al contesto
e verranno scompattati
nei paragrafi successivi che in esso risiede
un'evidente contraddizione tra queste
prime due premesse che è proprio come
il tallone d'achille  o il punto debole in
cui prenderanno di mira la loro logica
nella sezione
due, metteranno in discussione quel secondo
dei presupposti che è che la
cognizione sociale è cablata dalla nascita
e quindi mentre qualificano la
posizione di ttom
e dicono che più vessier lo fa  non detengono una
posizione nativista, ad esempio come una
pura prospettiva innata
perché si concentrano sulle
dinamiche evolutive ed ecologiche di
come viene acquisita la cultura
, mettono in discussione l'
acquisizione dello starter pack
e stanno anche esplorando di più in questa
sezione  alcune critiche inattiviste ad
esempio alle prospettive cablate sulla cognizione sociale
nella sezione 3 che
hanno criticato ipotesi che nella
loro mente evidenziano  la contraddizione
insita nel pensare attraverso altre
menti suggeriranno un'altra
relazione oh non ti piace quel piatto
proviamo questo
e questo sarà un
approccio dalla teoria dei sistemi dinamici
o dst scrivono
dst
come discuteremo in  questa sezione è un
approccio che serve per conoscere e
generare potere predittivo sulle
pratiche socioculturalmente situate degli
agenti che costruiscono la loro nicchia
perché dst ha al suo centro
strumenti utili come la
non linearità di emergenza e la spontaneità ecc.
ci permette di allontanarci dalle
nozioni prefabbricate  della teoria tom delle
teorie simili alla mente della cognizione sociale
si dovrebbe quindi astenersi dal fare
ipotesi
ontologiche ontologiche qui essendo su come
stanno le cose nel mondo
quindi più dell'ontologia dei filosofi
piuttosto che dell'informatica
gestione della conoscenza senso dell'ontologia
si dovrebbe astenersi dal fare  questo
tipo di ipotesi ontologiche
autorizzate dal realismo
sul complesso  sistema basato su un
modello trattabile
quindi solo perché il modello è così
trattabile
non significa che abbiamo la licenza
per fare ipotesi ontologiche
poiché il modello trattabile è
un'opportunità per conoscere il
comportamento complesso sono consentite solo le affermazioni epistemiche
facciamo un'analisi più approfondita  guarda l'affermazione
per renderlo trattabile possiamo rappresentare un
sistema dinamico da una
relazione statica come segue ed ecco le
loro equazioni una due e tre con
le didascalie sotto
e stanno usando questi
tipi molto semplici come il kernel dei
sistemi dinamici  la teoria è
capire come le
cose siano una funzione di come cambiano in
generale ed è rappresentato in alcuni
modi diversi
in termini di un modello successore e
più un modello di raggio di cambiamento
stephen penso che questo sia un
punto molto utile punto numero tre lì
il proiettile  punto perché parla
anche del senso che
questo è un approccio di modellazione
vediamo cosa
ci dice il modello piuttosto che un modello
adatto
avvicinati
ehm che spesso sai cosa finisce per
succedere se hai l'ontologia definita
conosci efficacemente
così tante cose quindi
um forse è un pezzo chiave
che
collega molto di come le cose possono essere colmate in
termini di inferenza attiva e come
potrebbe  essere tenuto tra
voi sai
che questa
è una posizione in un certo
senso è tenere le gambe divaricate e
dire
ok
sto facendo le spaccate o ho le
gambe unite
bene
quindi scopriamolo piuttosto che
tu qualcuno esperto mi dica
um
e
sì grazie
grazie decano sì
sì volevo solo aggiungere a ciò che
Stephen stava dicendo
fino a questo punto mi piace davvero e adoro
il giornale
che è il pezzo costruttivista
anche se penso che
mi abbia fatto una
pausa per un minuto perché ci
credo  per poter
prendere quella decisione
sono le spaccature o è un fork è
letteralmente un fork e invece di
dover andare da sinistra a destra ciò richiede una
decostruzione
che penso sia spesso tralasciata
prima  a una ricostruzione
quindi ancora una volta non discuto con gli
autori perché penso che stiano
rispettando l'autonomia
e penso che abbiano fatto un lavoro brillante nel
dire va bene questa logica questo
percorso deduttivo che altri autori hanno intrapreso
potrebbe non essere necessariamente applicabile qui
perché causa troppa miscelazione così buono buono
buono stai tenendo in alto ciò che in
realtà è sinistro e destro
ma stai tralasciando l'
aggiunta e la parte è che potrebbe essere una forchetta
che potrei letteralmente prendere e il  l'unico
modo in cui puoi vedere che è se puoi
decostruire
prima di ricostruire e decostruire
non significa differenziare che è
già presente decostruire letteralmente
significa come
l'unità
quando sono arrivato in questo momento
cosa ho quali parti del puzzle
mi mancano ancora  perché
ho fretta di capire se
dovrei andare a sinistra oa destra dopo,
specialmente nel contesto totale, specialmente
lì
sì stephen se vuoi dare un
rapido punto qui grazie solo aggiungendo a
quello um
quel pezzo della situazione
um
credo che sia qui che arrivi alla
consapevolezza di cosa sta succedendo, quindi la scienza ci
sta davvero dicendo cosa sta succedendo
cos'è quella cosa cos'è
questo cos'è quello
ma quel bivio o essere tu
conosci un  team team giunzione dell'età o
qualcos'altro alla
fine c'è un pezzo di consapevolezza
dove è quello situato e nell'inferenza attiva
che è spesso più
complesso
con l'essere scientifico sull'accuratezza
del metodo e
altre volte la consapevolezza e la
complessità arrivano nell'inferenza attiva possono
avere entrambi  quelli sì fantastico
continuando attraverso le ultime parti del
documento parlano molto della complessità che
molti di noi amano
così complessità complessità scienza
teoria della complessità porta così tanti
grandi
termini concetti persone metodi strumenti
idee tutto
e parlano molto di autopolitiche
e questa ricorsività  quindi ci sono molti
collegamenti di collegamento davvero creativi realizzati
nel documento inattivo e la complessità lo è
utilizzati in modo davvero prezioso
nella sezione
quattro, passeranno all'inferenza attiva
in un ambiente dinamico inattivo
ed è qui che l'inferenza
attiva verrà utilizzata come strumento perspicace
per conoscere e comprendere
le dinamiche alla base delle
co-costruzioni culturali
considerando che non prende necessariamente gli
agenti come agenti passivi
insieme sono gli autori
degli stati l'uno dell'altro
e quindi un
po' analoghi alle figure inattive
mostrate in precedenza in cui avevamo gli
ingranaggi nella testa
e poi andavano come se gli ingranaggi
fossero più distribuiti  nel corpo e
nella mente
qui nella figura 2 c'è più un
significato classico e un ragionamento basato su modelli in cui
diversi attori sociali hanno una sorta
di resoconto inferenziale che è
molto simile a una direzione, come mostrato qui
con una freccia che punta solo al
centro e  nella figura 3 descrivono
l'azione sociale nella figura 2 sotto l'
inferenza attiva in termini di etichettatura
qui
gli stati interni  dell'attore sociale
e degli stati esterni come
attore sociale uno, quindi questo è dal
punto di vista dell'attore sociale due in
cui gli stati generali sono
inquadrati come significato socioculturale e quel
ragionamento basato su modelli
che apre a resoconti inferenziali
che sono distribuiti
e messi in atto
e
[Musica]
speriamo di entrare più nel dettaglio
perché è qui che stanno
supportando la loro
applicazione strumentale positiva dell'inferenza attiva
nello spazio sociale inattivo
e poi scrivono caratterizzando una
scena sociale come analoga alla pratica scientifica
c'è una caratterizzazione errata è
quasi  come prendere ciò che accade in
laboratorio in un determinato contesto e anche
una certa visione di ciò che accade in
laboratorio in un determinato contesto
virgola in un determinato contesto
e poi criticarlo
e pensare un po' più ampiamente
a ciò che accade nei corridoi
del laboratorio  e nel seminterrato e
nel mondo intorno all'edificio
e quello è anche r  molto ben collegato
a qualche bronberg giallo a tutti il lavoro sul cerve
lo anticipante non è uno scien
iato che si concentra anche sulla prosp
ttiva inattiva da una prosp
ttiva ecologica non solo necessariamente il socia
e ma il sociale è un caso importante nella
tabella 1 di
ui discuteranno  un po' di
più su
alcuni dei divisori e dei contenuti delle
cellule relative al mondo naturale e sugli
strumenti e sui costrutti scientifici
di sicuro torneremo qui nelle
discussioni successive, quindi dai un'occhiata alla
tabella uno per
vedere cosa ne pensi
quali altre righe vorresti  disegnare
sarebbero un po' come linee curve come
sembri lettere vorresti cerchiare
qualcosa vorresti disegnare dei
triangoli aggiungeresti un'altra riga lo
faresti un tensore cos'altro disegneresti sul
tavolo uno
anche se solo un'altra doppia
linea di delimitazione da enfatizzare  che è perfetto come
è preside
tutto quello che direi è se vai
a dare un'occhiata a questo chiediti perché questi
parametri iper e perché
questi in ritardo  rals
perché penso che la volontà
che porterà a tutti i tipi di
bene per me mi ha appena contorto così tanto
divertimento
ok e poi conclusione prima di passare
al secondo articolo
abbiamo dimostrato che tenere sia un
attivismo che una teoria della mente comporta
contraddizione e  confusione
questo è evidente quando analizziamo criticamente
i due presupposti nascosti sostenuti
da teorie simili a tom come ttom che
sono respinte dall'inattivismo quei due
presupposti segreti che credono
discreditano il collegamento
e
quindi reiterano la natura co-costruttiva
e le componenti incorporate ed ecologiche
dell'inazione sociale
e della ricorsione e del dispiegarsi
nel tempo l'espandersi dell'inazione sociale
e suggeriscono che la
teoria dei sistemi dinamici
e l'inferenza attiva
applicata strumentalmente come un tipo di modellazione dei sistemi dinamici
ha una promessa
ed è uno strumento adatto e complementare
per considerare la comprensione sociale come
la sincronizzazione generalizzata si
manteneva in un certo modo,
così fu che p  aper e
ora sarà accoppiato
con la carta abduttiva quindi
un respiro prima di passare al rapimento
sì stephen
prendendo quel respiro um quell'ultima frase
lì su come può essere
um quasi un ponte sono l'
uso complementare della teoria dei sistemi dinamici
e in un certo senso riempiono un vuoto, stanno in qualche modo
colmando il vuoto e in un certo senso penso che mentre
parliamo del documento di rapimento alcuni
dei vuoti che non riempiono
lo so che non stiamo cercando di parlare di
colmare i vuoti qui ma  diciamo che stai
colmando le lacune che
potrebbe anche sentire l'abduzione, quindi conosci
la bellezza della bellezza dell'inferenza attiva
e l'approccio bayesiano è
che molte
scale e modalità diverse e possono essere
ponderate e mescolate per
darti potenzialmente un'idea
di cosa  fare bene
così non significa che uno escluda l'altro
fantastico
ok
interabduzione
noi ottiamo
il documento inizia con un'introduzione relativamente
breve e molto
concisa ad alcuni dei punti chiave
del documento che
abbiamo descritto in precedenza  r nei loro obiettivi
che sono interessati a questa resa naturalistica
di alcuni dei successivi lavori di CS pierce,
ad esempio post 1903 o post 1905, per
lo più inediti che
spacchettano le nozioni semiotiche e logiche
del ragionamento abduttivo che abbiamo
trattato nella sezione del contesto a
cui mirano  modello biologico
di abduzione
che sta per
infilare l'ago
tessere il tessuto qualunque esso sia
che mantenga l'integrità funzionale
dell'organismo
l'imperativo evolutivo per
l'esistenza di quell'essere vivente e per essere
compatibile con le moderne neuroscienze
si concentrano sulla fedeltà e l'
alleanza che noi  di cui abbiamo parlato prima
e introdurranno anche
nell'introduzione il concetto di coperta di markov
che sarà un ottimo punto di
giustapposizione per aggiungere un po' più di
dettaglio come se fosse un fronte un
fronte di contatto con inferenza attiva con
inazione sociale e rapimento
quindi questi  sono come punti caldi o punti
di contatto all'interno dell'interfaccia frontale per
ingrandire davvero bene come  è lo
stato interno utilizzato in questi due modelli ed è
qui che l'
ontologia di inferenza attiva è di immenso valore perché
anche quando le persone parlano in
lingue diverse o abbiamo un
programma per computer un'equazione una poesia e
poi un articolo scientifico
quando possiamo collegare e in modo proattivo  usiamo o
annotiamo in modo proattivo con l'
ontologia di inferenza attiva
otteniamo la capacità non solo di dire bene
stiamo entrambi indicando la luna
è il tuo dito il mio dito o stiamo
indicando lo stesso dito perché è
così lontano e quindi forse è un po'
un po 'e il tuo raggio manca della
luna dal mio punto di vista
e così via invece possiamo effettivamente
scendere e non
sanguinare sul tavolo operatorio
ma piuttosto fissare transitoriamente e trovare
un attrattore che ci aiuti davvero ad entrare in
quell'intersezione piuttosto  che semplicemente
colpire e correre con solo punti di
risonanza decano
sì di
nuovo lo riassumerò dicendo che
possiamo analizzare meglio la situazione
perché ora in realtà h  avere
un modo per essere in grado di tenere
insieme qualcosa di comune,
quindi è tutto ciò che voglio aggiungere a ciò che hai
appena detto
e aggiungerne solo uno anche a quello
è sì scusa ma um
e dove potrebbe esserci
una differenza quindi
sai come
potrebbe esserci questa comprensione di
molti termini la
comprensione ontologica e dire
quello che spesso è un problema è se c'è
qualcosa che non è
allineato ma
semplicemente non viene notato o viene ignorato dì
ok è diverso ok c'è un
cambiamento ontologico qui
c'è un  modo c'è c'è un
modo per farlo essere trattabile
come abbiamo con l'inferenza attiva è
un modo trattabile per farlo perché
altrimenti ci sono così tante
cose ontologiche che fluttuano in questo spazio
che è la sua bellezza
che non è cognitivamente
possibile trovare ciò che si  devo guardare
grazie ancora
la prossima
sezione con queste due luci
co-illuminanti co-costruzione
nessuna due luci possono sovrapporsi fisicamente quindi
ci deve essere parallasse indotta  da queste
due luci e ombre e tutti i tipi di
effetti e forse non è la stessa
lunghezza d'onda e forse stai
camminando e lati diversi hanno
illuminazioni diverse
la sezione è in inferenza attiva
alla luce del rapimento
questa
è una
sezione molto affascinante
perché '  prenderemo quel
quadro quasi quasi algoritmico ma sicuramente pre-calcolativo sviluppato negli ultimi anni del 1800
e all'inizio del 1900
e inizieremo a
interfacciarci e vedere
come si collega all'inferenza attiva in
modo da poter evidenziare di più e non vediamo l'
ora di discutere in  altre
sezioni quindi mettilo in pausa se vuoi
leggere tutto questo o leggere il documento
ma si stanno concentrando sullo schema tardivo
sì per favore decano tutto quello che stavo per dire
è che è l'illuminazione d'atmosfera se in realtà
guardi in basso il proiettile in basso il
l'illuminazione sta effettivamente provando, la
borsa ne ha parlato forse forse
non so se avesse davvero i
formalismi per sostenerlo,
ma l'inferenza attiva in realtà ora
parla di un  riguardo al tipo di
livello di energia
che ora possiamo forse
vedere all'interno dei due
vincoli che quell'idea di
um
parametrizzare di nuovo al tipo di presa della morsa
grazie quindi solo alcune citazioni che sono
davvero affascinanti qui
quindi
nella scienza rapimento  possono essere paragonati
alla logica della scoperta di ipotesi
che, come abbiamo discusso in precedenza, ha un
elemento creativo generativo e quindi una
componente selettiva secondaria come la
selezione del modello bayesiano la riduzione del modello bayesiano
e aggiungono anche con un'osservazione cautelativa
che non può verificarsi una piena
assimilazione del rapimento di Pearson
per ibe questa è un'inferenza alla
migliore spiegazione che è la metà del
motore a due tempi e comunemente le
persone useranno l'abduzione per riferirsi al
ragionamento probabilistico da un dato insieme
come l'abduzione altrove negli scritti
questo schema successivo
quelli che sono dopo il 1903
ma
secondo  per gli esperti sono stati i meno
ricercati a
cominciare da un'osservazione del
fattore sorprendente e  sfoga l'
osservazione sorpresa
e attraverso una premessa maggiore condizionale
conclude di nuovo in uno stato d'animo co-ortativo uno
stato d'animo
che ha definito l'investigatore
è come se avesse e proprio in esso
ed è che qualcosa di imperativamente
importante dovrebbe essere fatto
pragmatismo inazione selezione politica
inizialmente suscitata  per curiosità
riduzione dell'incertezza entropia
che porta alla formulazione di una
domanda
che è semantica
e
c'è più discussione
sull'umore investigativo e su altri stati d'animo
sì dean un'altra cosa veloce
coorte o co-costruita
dall'altro articolo
condividiamo di nuovo un prefisso comune che noi di
nuovo  penso che forse sarà in grado di
stuzzicare un
po' di più
l'importanza del fatto che nei prossimi
livestream
fantastici continueranno con questa
domanda sull'economia della ricerca,
quindi
hanno formato tre corsi argomentativi
aree di contatto davvero specifiche con l'
inferenza attiva  e il rapimento
che stanno suggerendo formano un trio
o triade iniziale
che sarà il protagonista  t per formare la fedeltà
tra inferenza attiva e abduttiva
prima la presenza di
relazioni triadiche non degenerative
poi l'utilizzo dei principi guida
del ragionamento abduttivo
b e in terzo luogo la formulazione condizionale congiuntiva
ci sono alcuni tecnicismi logici
gettati in giro, ma è a
questo che servono i flussi
nel punto a
cui puoi fermarti e leggere il testo di
loro evidenzieranno il
concetto di coperta markov
o meglio la
loro
interpretazione realista come prima e coperte
e
sosterranno
che
le coperte markov implementate di nuovo in
un primo momento realista e in senso generale
hanno un marcatamente penetrante
forma irriducibilmente triadica
focalizzata sul confine come mediatore
tra stati interni esterni e
quindi la terzietà che sorge nella
semiosi
c'è molto altro da dire ma se uno
di voi due vuole dare un punto in più su un
ok in
b continuerà per  parlare
di alcuni dei principi guida
dell'inferenza
e discutere specificamente ab  ruolo della duzione
nel guidare l'inferenza
qual è il principio guida delle
inferenze attive quindi
qui descriveranno alcuni
dettagli tecnici dell'inferenza attiva in
termini di energia libera variazionale o
attesa come sorpresa limite
e poi lo collegheranno ad alcuni
dei primari  fonti di sfondamento e
discussioni di biosemiotica che sono
state anche collegate in molte
discussioni che abbiamo avuto sulla
rappresentazione e sul significato e così via
e
si spinge ancora oltre o più in profondità
con le discussioni sul
sinechismo e su questa
questione della mente universale che  è l'
invecchiamento della forza in qualche modo la
cognizione universale pan dinamica
cognitiva sistemi cognitivi distribuiti
materia è mente debole di von schiller
e poi discuteranno delle
coperte incontaminate e della loro costruzione
in termini di relazioni triadiche
pearson triade segno oggetto interprete formica
porta a inesplorato  possibilità semantiche
che riuniscono alcuni di questi
fili qualitativi più ampi i  n analisi semiotica
con
metodi bayesiani quantitativi della teoria dei sistemi potenzialmente dinamici e
tutto ciò che l'inferenza attiva
porta con sé con i toolkit per
implementare
e vedere
che stanno anche in c spacchettano alcuni
elementi costruttivi logici estremamente interessanti anche se sfumati
della proposizione semiotica
se potessi  chiamalo
così, approfondiscilo
di più in ulteriori discussioni,
ma esploreranno in che
modo i diversi
inquadramenti delle relazioni logiche
tra clausole o affermazioni e
garanzie e tutta questa retorica si
riferiscono al
rapimento del realismo
e
alla versione del realismo di pierce poiché il
possibile è ciò che può diventare reale
sì ci sono cose che sono possibili
ma non possono diventare reali e quindi
cosa usiamo per quel possibile adiacente o
realizzabile
e
dove potremmo volerlo usare e
cosa romperà quella simmetria dove sta
bene il pragmatismo cosa sarebbe utile
considerare sarebbe  lo spazio di tutti i
possibili che potrebbero accadere e nessun
altro e n  Non essere sorpreso da
possibili adiacenti che non abbiamo considerato
ma sono accaduti
e quindi forse non è così male spendere
un po' di pensiero in più o alcune
risorse extra del computer per considerare
possibilità che non potrebbero accadere
ma non vorremmo  perdersi nello
spazio potenzialmente esponenziale delle
possibilità che non possono accadere
e finire per perdere la concentrazione e l'
attenzione sulle possibilità che possono
accadere che sono ciò che Pierce descrive
come possibilità reali
e la posizione e l'umore pragmatici
chiudono anche il cerchio con la
selezione delle politiche e  pragmatismo nell'inferenza attiva in
cui dicono che il
significato pragmatico delle credenze nella formulazione di Bane Paris
è quello su quello su cui si è in
grado di agire
e ci sono molte risonanze lì
stephen
sì, penso che questo parli anche
della necessità di avere
parliamo di scala amichevole o livelli
o
conosci una sorta di struttura che
consente a
questo di essere presente perché
sai che l'influenza attiva può farlo  rt di
andare fino in fondo e portato giù al
livello cellulare dato che ci sono modi
di guardarlo
qui c'è la sensazione che ok stiamo
guardando
queste um
idee di um un significante
ma sappiamo con un'inferenza attiva che
non è quello  crede che abbiamo
segnali in arrivo in cui vengono elaborati
e aggregati
quindi c'è una sorta di scala in
cui hai le strutture che
hai la
morfogenesi forse per arrivare a
una scala per
dare un senso al segnale di stop
da
interpretare
come suo  proprio
significante quindi penso che potrebbe essere
dove accadrà questa um tensione
tra gli inattivisti qui e e
dove ciò può accadere, ma l'argomento che
potrei dire è che certe
scale ridimensionano
determinate strutture
e forse certi
modi realistici di cose che accadono
qualcosa come  questo
è fattibile
fantastico, solo preside e poi ci
sposteremo rapidamente attraverso il resto fammi solo essere molto
veloce qui penso soprattutto in b
e e fino a misura minore e c
l'autobus  Il modo in cui prendiamo i piercing il
pensiero penetrante
nel regno dell'inferenza attiva
è costruito su un presupposto e cioè
che il continuare la nostra
esistenza continua la nostra
realtà continua
significa che stiamo accumulando più
esperienze con gli strumenti
nel mondo le regole nel  mondo e
le piscine e per piscine intendo quelle
aggregazioni che Stephen stava solo
indicando per ringraziarti per averlo
sollevato steven perché questo mi ha fatto venire voglia di
scrivere queste aggregazioni come
densità
racconto di due densità che si materializzano
così di nuovo non so
che tu
dire esclusivamente che tutto è reale e
poi anche tutti gli esempi sottostanti sono
reali perché anche lo stesso pierce ha
detto che c'è un aspetto di questa
realtà che non
potremo mai descrivere come nient'altro
che
non-realtà
anche se fondamentalmente stiamo usando
così come fa
come fa a
permettere a queste densità di formarsi e
so che suona davvero dannatamente e se ne è andato
là fuori
mi dispiace ma è  in realtà qualcosa che
dobbiamo contemplare
grazie poi
capovolgeranno il copione o almeno la sintassi
e parleranno di abduzione alla luce
dell'inferenza attiva
ecco da dove iniziano con quel
riconoscimento del motore a due tempi
con abduzione generativa e  abduzione selettiva
e poi la collegheranno
ad alcune ontologia dell'inferenza attiva
in termini di come vedere
l'abduzione selettiva
come un
processo di campionamento
e capire dove si
inserisce l'abduzione generativa,
continuando così a vedere l'abduzione
dalla luce dell'inferenza attiva che
potremmo anche rendere operativi come dire
come
inquadrare o vedere l'abduzione
dalla prospettiva dell'ontologia di inferenza attiva,
quindi piuttosto che
auto-eleggerci
come interpretazione dell'inferenza attiva come
un
concetto di cui non possiamo necessariamente
parlare per un concetto
non possiamo parlare per l'inglese ma  possiamo
usare parole inglesi
e così, analogamente, non abbiamo bisogno
di parlare per forza attiva  rence
sebbene io sia l'ultimo a dire cosa
dovrebbero o non dovrebbero fare
è possibile
usare l'ontologia di inferenza attiva e
quindi è un po' come se una
lista di controllo in due fasi
fosse il termine nell'atto di inferenza
ontologia nel supplemento principale o
sezioni implicate è
stato utilizzato
in un modo pragmatico che aveva
senso in quella situazione
in quel contesto multiscala
e che in realtà è un processo in due fasi
per chiedere se stiamo parlando
usando l'inferenza attiva piuttosto che se
stiamo parlando per  come un avvocato o
come un venditore per l'inferenza attiva di
per sé
e riaffermeranno il caso in
termini di quadro fap nel
senso e usando i termini di
ed evidenzieranno la
relazione tra stati interni
ed esterni  stati mediati attraverso la
coperta
e poi passano attraverso questo sillogismo
e ristrutturano e riaffermano il loro
schema qualitativo di inferenza abduttiva attiva
e descrivono questo
ciclo di percezione cognitiva di azione in
cui
un surp  ogni
informazione sensoriale in entrata viene sperimentata
e poi la
prendono non solo nell'interpretazione passiva
o addirittura attiva di essa
nel contesto di un modello generativo bayesiano
,
ma piuttosto qualcosa che si sta svolgendo
in quello stato d'animo dell'investigatore
che continuano
e portano dentro  uh idea penetrante importante
dell'economia della ricerca
quindi lo esamineremo di nuovo, si spera
con gli autori
um si riferisce alla teoria della
scienza di
pierce l'articolo originale di pierce nel 1970 o 1876
sull'economia della ricerca ha
scritto la dottrina dell'economia in generale
tratta le relazioni  tra utilità
e costo
e in particolare che sarà
correlato alla ricerca in questo
senso pragmatico socialmente sancito
chiedendosi come, dato il dispendio di denaro,
tempo ed energia,
cosa otterrà l'aggiunta più preziosa
alla conoscenza
quale esperimento che i miei occhi potrebbero
cicadere a volontà  avere il maggior numero di informazioni
ottenere
quali esperimenti potrebbe effettuare il ricercatore
per ridurre la propria incertezza
non solo per verificare qualcosa che sanno
non solo per falsificare qualcosa che
sanno sarà falsificato, ma piuttosto
per esistere in questo spazio di sperimentazione ottimale
e poi trafiggere e poi gli
autori naturalizzare contestualizzare
portare al sociale  area cognitiva
chiedendosi bene come accadono denaro tempo ed
energia perché quell'esperimento ottimale
è in coltura e usa
energia usa reagenti quindi forse in
questo modo potremmo dire che pierce è stato
uno dei primi gestori di programmi moderni
per una grande agenzia di finanziamento ma  no non lo
era e hanno discusso
un po' di più questa economia della ricerca
descrivono in questa sezione
come la perforazione
promuova diversi
valori o virtù o qualità
che caratterizzano l'economia
dell'ipotesi scientifica facendo
nella complessità
che è come un'ampiezza de-rischio
che parla a  l'unificazione
e la cautela
come qualità economica dell'evitare
rendimenti marginali decrescenti
rompendo abilmente  ng giù le domande
in una serie di piccole domande a cui è
possibile rispondere con ragionevoli limiti
di investimento
quanti thread interessanti vengono
riuniti
ad esempio domande che sono
scomposte in binari sì no domande
possono essere collegate anche alla teoria dell'informazione
e quantistica
qui dean  ti lascerò
parlare per correttezza
lo leggerò solo per essere corretto e, come
brevemente all'inizio di questo articolo,
non ci sono
interpretazioni strumentali del fep e dei suoi
ingredienti come le coperte di markov
ma
questa è una nota a piè di pagina in questo articolo ma la nostra
fede  per una parola migliore e
credenziali realistiche di fep come le sue radici
nell'ottimismo pragmatista pragma o
piuttosto il suo atto di ameliarismo sui
guadagni derivanti dall'alleanza tra
processi evolutivi evolutivamente utili per contribuire a massimizzare la
sopravvivenza
se questo approccio pragmatico al realismo
dispiace agli elevati  gusto di chi
cerca qualche fedele
criterio metafisico lascia mille
fiori bl  oom penso che la cosa affascinante
di questo sia
che sostenere l'idea che ci sia un realismo
sia una posizione facilmente difendibile da
prendere ma anche nella diapositiva precedente una
delle cose di cui si è
parlato per la prima volta senza dirle
direttamente o almeno non in  quelle citazioni
erano che
quella posizione ottimale è un qualche
elemento di sfruttamento o economia
o semplicità o o qualcuno l'ha fatto
prima di me
è che una scorciatoia
e un'esplorazione che tende a richiedere
più tempo ha più
tentativi ed errori
ma anche non ti fa
adattarsi costantemente
per un risultato particolare
quindi
um
questa è la realtà
e ancora una volta non lo farei non respingerei
l'affermazione che c'è un pezzo molto
reale
in questo
suonare un minimo di due che vanno avanti e
indietro in questo
um
quindi sono  non solo infatti sono pienamente d'accordo con
questi autori come sono pienamente d'accordo con
gli altri autori
sull'idea di una co-costruzione quindi
non so che
tu sei
tu sei necessariamente ehm confuso se
puoi dire sì e sì e di nuovo sì
steven
sì in qualche modo aggiungendo a ciò che viene detto
lì e
l'idea di
implementazione o
sfruttamento è sicuramente allude
e nella scienza
c'è la
sperimentazione è una specie di modo per
acquisire conoscenza
ma c'è il pezzo di esplorazione e
mio direi che
non puoi ottenere l'
esplorazione di per sé all'interno
del tipo di
dominio oggettivo ci deve essere questo
viaggio nel nel nel
performativo nel soggettivo nel soggettivo
liminale come ha fatto Einstein con i suoi giochi mentali
e tu crei questo tipo  di
mentale uh costruisce in un certo modo ciò che parte
di ciò che sta accadendo oggi è un misto
di quello e poi è stato riportato indietro
e modellato sperimentato con qualunque cosa
um
quindi penso che ci sia una modellazione intendo è
interessante perché
è uh in qualche modo può venire in quel
viaggio un  anche un po',
quindi
potrebbe essere qualcosa che gli
esperimenti non possono fare
ecco un riassunto di una vecchia persona che scherza a
dice a
e l'arbitro  eree dice che hai ragione la persona
b dice b l'arbitro dice che hai ragione
e la persona c dice bene aeb non può avere
ragione e l'arbitro dice che sai
che hai ragione
è un po' di umorismo rapido per quelli a cui
piace  genere
um hanno poi una sezione conclusiva
e
abbiamo molte domande e punti da
fare e molte connessioni da riportare
a molta naturalizzazione qui
come i campi in levin
work e lo portano persino alle
capacità rigenerative dei vermi piatti quindi
dai
vermi piatti ai coinquilini,
ecco dove andiamo oggi
e poi abbiamo anche risparmiato per il punto
uno
parte della giustapposizione del
concetto di coperta di markov, in particolare
le componenti sociali e attive della
scienza che sono super importanti e la
maestà ha portato a queste
le discussioni precedenti sono un ottimo punto
di contatto con la carta abduttiva e
le
coperte di markov di carta socialmente inattive rappresentano come un
fronte di contatto tecnico anche molto limitato che fornirà molte
discussioni  ione nel punto uno
ed è qui
che chiudiamo il punto zero
con uh di
nuovo così tanto eccellente lavoro di base e
imballaggio dello zaino
da parte di Dean e Steven, quindi
c'è qualcos'altro che vorresti aggiungere
a questo punto o qualsiasi altra cosa di cui
vuoi discutere  nel punto uno sì
decano poi stephen se vuoi daniel
fantastico lavoro abbiamo appena fatto un ordine di
grandezza 3 da quello che era tipicamente un
singolo live streaming cartaceo e lo abbiamo ancora
ricevuto in meno di due ore così
sei tu  per essere applaudito per questo e in
secondo luogo voglio solo
come forse un po 'di suggerimento per il
punto uno c'è una ricerca di
nome israel israel nunez che parla di
se vuoi essere in grado di
guardare come vengono decostruite le cose  e
costruito devi guardare entrambi i
prodotti in lavorazione un esempio è come
faccio a costruire un'auto
ed elaborare in prodotto
qual è la cosa che è un
punto di diramazione o un vero utensile
e quindi se apri la tua mente
a  sia che inversione
lungo quello
continuum apre tutti i tipi di possibilità
in termini di portare le cose in un luogo in
cui non entrano necessariamente in
conflitto sì possono integrarsi in treccia
e quindi forse sarà
dopo oggi
qualcosa che le persone che stanno usando l'
inferenza attiva che nel mio  l'opinione riguarda
sia il prodotto che il processo e il processo e il
prodotto
allo stesso tempo è la pinza e
l'impugnatura forse ci penseranno un
po'
è quasi come se il pragmatico vedesse la
forcella sulla strada e la usasse
e forse tu  usa la forchetta andando in un
modo e forse lo raccogli
forse lo usi completando l'impostazione della tavola
per qualcun altro che cenerà
lì e quindi ci sono così tanti modi da usare
perché l'uso è
socialmente emanato abduttivo
contestualizzato ecc
e di nuovo al  fork
è dove sta avvenendo quella conversazione
e nel nostro sito sul campo o al campo base è
dove possiamo immaginare i bivi e le
strade che incontreranno stephen
yeah e next nel nel  punto uno
per trovare un modo
per
portare gli autori se chiunque è lì che
conosci durante un viaggio forse giù per
uno dei bivi forse va fino al
bordo del lago e dobbiamo entrare
e bagnarci un po',
quindi come  può l'
abduzione scientifica o alcuni dei tipi di modelli più
scientificamente vincolati
regole suffragate dalla
sperimentazione e dalla strumentazione ok
quando questo viene spostato forse a
causa della partecipazione forse a causa
della transdisciplinarietà forse a causa di
processi di trasformazione forse a causa
di una profonda esplorazione
al di fuori del campo ehm  Mi chiedo che questo sia
qualcosa che potresti voler pensare a
come possiamo
dare
una sorta di chiare
opzioni di viaggio in modo che possano
venire
un po' fuori senza rimanere bloccati
in una che conosci nelle sabbie mobili o
annegare nell'acqua profonda,
giusto  quindi vogliamo una sorta di navigazione,
ma penso che questo sia dato da
alcuni di quei puntatori um penso a
dove ci sono una
sorta di
rampe di waze off così come  on-ramps quindi
grazie
grazie amici
è stato enorme apprezzo davvero
tutto il vostro aiuto
momenti fantastici ci vediamo nella bambola
tu